ينضم الينا من جده الفنان السعودي فواز
الزهراني فواز يسعد صباحك اهلا بك نحييك
على هالموهبه جدا الجميله يسعد صباحك فواز
صباح النور
كيف بديت مع الاخراج والتصوير عمل الحروب
اكشن اكثر
هو هو حوش فاضي يمكن اعطاني الوان الله
يعطيه العافيه هو ما يد يعني اللي صاير
الان في الحوش تخصصته بس
بالضبط فاستغربت حتى الايجار هذا اللي
شايفينها هي كانت مرميه يعني في الحوش
نفسها من الامطار رجعت زرعتها بس عشان
تعطيني الديكور اللي انتم شايفين وعند
الغرفه زي اللي وراء برضه بعنيها من خشب
وفيها برضه فيها اشياء جميله طيب
الحمد لله اول شيء يعني انا ما اعتبر اني
وصلت مرحله
الاحتراف
انا تعلم لسه يعني
وطورتها حبه حبه بالتركيز على النقطه
نفسها يعني على ما تفرعت ركزت على نقطه
انه انا
مخرج اكشن ومعارك
وموديل اكشن وممثل اكشن فعلشان كده طولت
نفسي كانت النقطه هذه عشان اكون اقوى طب
حدثنا عن ابرز الاعمال والافلام اللي
شاركت فيها يا فواز
انا شاركت كمخرج معارك مسلسلين تقريبا
شاهد
وشاركت في اعلانات
زي بطوله كورديوتي
واعلانات البنك الرياض كلها تتكلم عن
الجنود وتتكلم عن الحد وفي اكشن
يا فواز ابراهيم رايك
الحقيقيه رجل
من شكله رياكشن فالناس حبتها حبت الشيء
هذا همم اتوقع انه لازم في اي مسلسل او اي
فيلم
العسكري يبانون بالطريقه الصح طب نشوف جزء
من اعمالك هلا على الهواء يا فواز ونرجع
لك
[موسيقى]
شفنا في المقاطع اللي كنا نعمل المشاهده
هلا على الهواء مع المشاهدين انك تستخدم
مؤثرات هل هذه مؤثرات حقيقيه فالمشاهد
الحقيقيه
طيب
لاحظتوا لي لفتني يا فواز انك قبل اي عمل
لاحظناك ترسم قبل اي عمل لك ما ترسم تحديد
بالضبط انا طبعا هي غالبا ما تكون الفكره
في المخ يعني ما اكتبها ولكن ست الفترات
الاخيره عشان لما انزل للسته واصور ما ما
تشتت فركز على رسمه معينه اسمها من بدايه
من اول ما تيجي كده بحيث انه انسخها يعني
وقت التصوير مجرد اعطالك الورقه اتذكر ايش
اللي كنت
طيب اعمالك تنتقمها ان هناك
فواز كيف رايت تفاعل المنتجين معك هل تم
تقديم عروض لك على هذه الاعمال بعد مشاهده
واش الحمد لله هذا الشيء اللي يديني يدافع
اني اسوي الافضل
لكن لسه الان ما جاء على شيء يعني ما
اتكلمني ابدا بس ان شاء الله قريب يعني ان
شاء الله اتمنى لك كل التوفيق شكرا جزيلا
مجدل الفنان السعودي فواز الزهراني شكرا
لك فواز